[Musique]
ben pourquoi pas mais quoi qu'est ce
qu'il a envie de faire mathieu dans la
vie en fait quel type d'émission il a
envie de l'animé c'est la question que
je me pose moi il s'appelle je pense
qu'on a déjà touché le derrière parce
qu'elle est déjà venu sur le plateau de
ça même sera peut-être pas mais je crois
qu'il ya déjà c'est à dire que j'ai
ramené un peu et puis quand cyril
hanouna est arrivé je me suis dit ça y
est c'est match entre quoi est peut-être
même des gens qui me donnent des
émissions parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils
les donnent à cyril hanouna bon
présentateur préféré à part cyril c'est
une bonne émission
je suis fan inconditionnel de ioukos il
trouve en étant numéro 1 de tf1 reste un
mec génial à l'antenne dans la vie super
sympa super carré est super content